وخلينا نبقى في اخبار حقوق المراه
والانتهاكات بحقها ولكن هذه المره من مكان
ثاني ونوع اخر امل ودخل في التعليم ولا في
السفر هذه المره الي شلحوثي طلعت اقرار
اعجب واعلنت منع المراه من انها تدخل ورشه
تصليح سيارات من دون محرم ففي دكتور اسمها
انجيلا ابو اصبع رئيسه مؤسسه انجيلا
للتنميه والاستجابه الانسانيه صار معها
موقف غريب وحكيته في بوست على صفحتها
الشخصيه قالت فيه انها كانت متوجهه الورشه
لتصليح او الورشه تصليح سيارات علشان تفحص
سيارتها وعلى الباب منعو هذا يدخل الورشه
لانه ما معها محرم وعلى الرغم من الناقه
التي لهم منها دكتور وانه ابوها مسافر
واخوها في شغله واصغر منها اصلا ومعها هذا
ما خلوها تدخل وتفحص سيارتها من غير ما
يكون معاها محرم ودجه المنصات باسم
الدكتوره واللي صار معها ولكن من بعدها او
من بعد ساعات تحديدا من نشر البوست حذفته
من على صفحتها الشخصيه وعلى فكره القرار
بمنع المراه من التحرك بلا محرم كانت في
العام الماضي وبررت ان المراه شخص غير
مؤهل للتحكم في حياته
[موسيقى]